[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsay show where
america hangs out to have a conversation
about your life your money your career
your relationships and everything in
between i'm george campbell ramsey
personality joined today by my friend
ken coleman and we are here to help you
to take your calls to give you some
affirmation inspiration motivation
education whatever you need
we are here for you open phones this
hour triple eight eight two five five
two five is the number eight eight two
five five two two five sorry about that
you know you flub it up there's a lot of
twos a lot of fives can a lot of twos a
lot of fives and uh you're just getting
warmed up joe i'm just getting warmed up
i called you joe see it's friday night
oh see if you're paying attention see
you're already in the zone well dave
collins dave called me joe camel i think
the first time i was ever on the show
i was wondering if you were gonna catch
the slight reference but hey the phones
are ready to go people are calling in
and we're ready to help let's go let's
do it john is kicking us off in
effingham illinois john welcome to the
ramsay show
hey guys how you doing doing well how
are you how can we help
i'm doing great
so i've got a question on whether my
wife and i can afford a a new house a a
next house
last year we made a hundred and ten
thousand dollars um
that's that's what we brought home
excuse me that is
before taxes
um this year our average bring home has
been about six thousand dollars a month
so the house that we're looking at we've
agreed on a price of 290 000
and all of my numbers um between
investments that we would pull out
um a gift from from a family member and
the sell of our house i'm looking at
someplace between 14
and 1700 a month
so the math adds up in my head
but i want to make sure that there's
nothing that i'm missing and why do i
still have this feeling in my stomach
that's a it's a great question did you
pull those numbers on a 15-year mortgage
or 30-year
that's a 30-year ah
okay well that throws a wrench in the
plans here because i'm only going to
steer you towards that 15-year mortgage
and that's going to increase that
monthly payment
okay so tell me about these investments
you said you're pulling from these
investments is this outside of
retirement just a brokerage account
yeah it's outside of retirement so my
wife and i uh we've been saving since we
were 18
through through a big company and then
we also have i have a 401k
she has a pension and then we have some
other investments so this is this is
aside from our primary retirement okay
so what is causing the urgency to to
jump into this new house
so
the house that we're currently in uh
we've got two boys um three and gonna be
one next month and our house is 1300
square foot obviously people make it on
less
the house that's available i've lived in
my town ever since i was just a wee guy
and i've always loved the house
our minister originally owned it and
somebody else bought it and now i have
an opportunity to to occupy it and it's
a fantastic house
it would be it would be our
forever home until we retire
wow
forever home always scares me ken
oh we get too much emotion
that's the short answer too much emotion
on this let me just break this down john
the one and three-year-old boy have no
stinking clue
how big or small your house is 1300
square feet to a one and three-year-old
boy or one or three-year-old girl they
don't even have any clue and my brother
and i we
shared a room
uh in a house that size probably until i
was 12.
and then my dad finished the attic and i
was so desperate to get out of the room
with my brother i lived in the attic it
was fabulous i didn't know
but we lived in bunk beds i mean here's
my point
you're kind of going well we've got two
boys and the house is small
yeah but that's not a reason to move the
real reason you want to move is because
you've always had your eye on this house
and i totally understand that i'm not
knocking it but you're not ready yeah
you're not ready based on what we teach
and so
you gotta have to get over the emotion
here it's not your only forever house
john what's the total amount of down
payment you could put down on this right
now
so
with our investments and a gift from a
family member that puts us up to
uh 55 000 and with the sell of our home
that should put us someplace between 80
and 100 000 as a down payment
yeah after all the closing costs and
everything well i'm on the mortgage
calculator here at ramseysolutions.com
and i'm i'm crunching the numbers for
you to give you an idea and you are
about if you could put 140 down i would
feel very comfortable with you guys
doing this which means there's a gap
right here which means we've got to be
patient we've got to
sacrifice hustle whatever you got to do
to get to that number and it's not
because you have to follow the ramsey
rules to a t it's because too much of
your take-home pay is going to be tied
up in this mortgage and you're not going
to be able to accomplish all of your
other financial goals saving for college
paying off the house early having a life
going on vacation because you jumped in
this house before you were ready
okay
yeah it stinks doesn't it
my my biggest question is and you would
mention the the sacrifice
so our boys are three and one they're
not going to know if we don't go to
disney world they're not going to know
about the vacations
so our logic was okay we can we can
hustle i got i got a big raise this last
year
projected to make another big race for
next year
so
our estimate was well let's sacrifice
for a couple of years they're we're not
going to disney world we don't have any
intentions on anytime soon
and we spend the majority of our time on
our home if we were to if we were to
sacrifice you know cut back on on lots
of things which we already do
if we were to go through and sacrifice a
little bit more
for for the house that we know i mean
our our neighborhood i left out a lot
about our neighborhood just because i
didn't want to make it even more
personal but our neighborhood's really
gone downhill i've
i found methamphetamine in my backyard
somebody was hiding underneath my shed
we've had some sex predators down the
street
but we do have some other motivations
but yeah but i mean you're right it is
an emotional thing with the house but
i do wonder like they're not gonna know
there's other places you can live that
may be more affordable and if you if you
really need to get out right now but it
sounds like if you look for the reasons
why you need to get in this house right
now you'll find them and if you look for
the reasons why this is a bad move
financially for your financial future
you'll also find it so you're going to
find what you're looking for there
when it comes down to it i want you guys
to have margin in your life and right
now this plan doesn't do that for you
okay
so
i mean that's our take you you can do
what you want but if you're going to
follow the ramsey plan to the freedom
that millions have done to where you can
pay off your house become an everyday
millionaire all that stuff this is the
way to do it do you guys have any
consumer debt
we just have one car
but it'll be paid off in a year's time
man do you have an emergency fund fully
funded three to six months
yeah we've got twelve thousand dollars
in that and that's that's without
touching it we wouldn't be touching it
for the for the down payment what's on
the car loan
twenty thousand
man so so the the plan was
without the house to knuckle down and
get that
out of our life
and
after talking to the people on the home
they're looking at
probably selling it in julyish
and so we would be able to okay let's
let's knuckle down let's say we might
have to a sell the car
or b keep the car i think this thing
either needs to get sold or you're
putting extra paws before you jump into
this house you got to get out of debt
man you got to get that emergency fund
back in place once you pay off the debt
then we're working on saving up for this
house but if you do things out of order
and you do 17 things at once you'll
never get to where you want to go
thanks for the call john wishing the
best for you this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
life is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and longest serving
christian health cost sharing ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981.
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community of believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more verse
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
hey folks welcome back to the ramsay
show i'm george campbell joined today by
my colleague ken coleman
listen it has been a long time way too
long since we've been able to talk about
our live events but this week we finally
got to kick off a couple of events we're
planning for later this year so excited
we're talking about real live events ken
with the real people and every single
people
in the room it's very exciting we're
excited to say the least and we have a
lot of events coming up this year and
i'm especially looking forward to smart
conference that's right smart conference
is back it's been three years and we're
so pumped to get this conference back on
the road in dallas texas we're going to
dallas on saturday october 22nd and
smart conference is our biggest event of
the year you don't want to miss it it's
going to be a day-long jam-packed event
well you'll where you'll get advice from
leading experts on money personal growth
leadership mental health and your career
you're going to leave with all the
knowledge and motivation that you need
to live the life you want all of the
ramsay personalities are going to be
there plus craig rochelle and his wife
talking about marriage
it's going to be a great time so get
your tickets right now they're moving
real fast just 39
that's amazing it's honestly i've told
dave this it's too good of a deal yeah
you've got to be there that's a great
price for a full day event like this so
get your tickets now before they sell
out you can go to ramseysolutions.com
events to learn more and join us in
dallas texas are you going to wear the
uh you know the kind of the old school
country music star full-on suit with
sequins and tassels i've been known to
pull out a little rose the rose shirt
yeah if you're a little guy and you
would look kind of fun in that thank you
for that a little guy where's the well
we're not going to the rodeo ken
i just think it would connect you to the
audience a little bit more i appreciate
it's all i'm saying well i haven't
thought about wardrobe ken you're
thinking ahead uh that's what i do well
open phones this hour we'd love to take
your call on money and especially career
there's so much out there if it's a
toxic environment
you've got a boss you can't stand you're
looking to increase your income get a
bigger shovel so you can accomplish your
financial goals ken coleman is the
expert on that i'm ready to help him and
if you've got any questions you need
some affirmation sometimes you think you
know the answer and you just want to
hear from a third party to go yes i was
thinking that way or i think this is a
dumb thing and i just need someone to
talk me off the ledge we're happy to do
that too sounds like parenting teenagers
but you were talking about the show
that's a great opportunity yeah i got
three teens at home that's what i feel
like on a daily basis i feel like i need
a third party person to tell me uh talk
me off a ledge i love that well either
way we are here for your phone number to
call get this down triple eight eight
two five five two two five you'll get
patched through to our friend kelly and
if you're nice to her she will let you
through on the air that's the key be
nice to kelly she holds the keys to the
kingdom powerful woman all right well
let's go to those phone lines todd joins
us in washington d.c todd welcome to the
ramsey show
hey how you all doing today great how
are you
i'm doing great hey um we're we're doing
really good with the program we've you
know we've got our baby steps going
right and uh i did have a quick question
about the emergency fund and me and my
wife are going back and forth
so when they say you should have three
to six months is that that's the expense
is not of your income correct correct
so
what do you so with the extra word we're
debt-free other than our mortgage we
have no consumer debt awesome
and we have a 15-year mortgage that we
refinanced a couple years maybe a year
ago so we got a 30 and we were just want
to pay this thing down quicker so
what i guess we're asking is so any
extra money over what we currently have
in our current bank savings which gives
you nothing in interest we all know
um
should that go straight to the mortgage
for one to balance
i would think yes because you guys
always say you should try to get that
paid off as soon as you can
but what about the emergency fund should
that stay liquid like in the bank or
would it be okay to invest that into
like a mutual fund or something one
thousand percent no we are not investing
the emergency fund that is a recipe for
disaster have you seen the stock market
today if you had your hvac go out
and your money just dropped you know
five grand that's a bad situation so
here's how we look at it
your emergency fund is insurance it's
not an investment right okay it's there
to protect you
when murphy hits when life goes wrong
when the stock market's down when the
hvac goes out the tire goes flat the job
gets lost all of those things and so no
i know you're going man i could be
making money right now but that's not
the point of the emergency fund that is
what you're investing is for in baby
step four
so do you guys have the emergency fund
are you saying you're working on it
oh we got yeah we definitely got it we
have more than in the back right now how
much are we talking how many months
so i got six months
save plus with the extra probably
covering another three wow so i got
about nine months yeah wow well why
don't you take that extra three and
throw it on the mortgage
that's what i'm thinking about doing
that's what i was asking yeah i think
that might be a good shot
that's the plan man what's left on the
mortgage
um right now we got about 355 left on it
our uh if we sold it on the market right
now we probably get six and up so we got
good equity in it okay
um and you know we're both in our early
60s we uh want to retire my wife is
going to retire soon to do part-time
um so we're just trying to our biggest
thing is the quicker we get this thing
paid off the better off we're going to
be and we know that what you're going to
want to buy what's your combined income
right now
um combined income we bring about
about 210 a year in
wow
okay so if you cut the check today
um with the additional three months of
your emergency fund so we still have six
months in there how much is that going
to drop the uh the mortgage balance to
let's say probably
seeing 20. i'd say about it it'd drop it
down to about three
probably 320 maybe yeah with that kind
of income um even if your wife dropping
down to part-time income you guys still
have a really healthy income and you're
gonna be able to knock that out you're
on the road
yeah that's what we've been trying to
really focus on you know because i think
that's i kind of agree with you all's
principle but get rid of the debt get
rid of the mortgage i've always said
you don't need as much to live in
retirement if you don't have a mortgage
that's the truth and that's what i was
going to ask you i want you to have a
paid for house before you guys retire so
that you can retire with dignity do you
guys have a nest egg saved how much is
in investments
um we don't really currently have other
things other than my 401k and her 401k
so that's about we got about combined
almost 500 000. okay well let's let's
keep it that let's keep doing the 15
percent are you doing that already
introducing actually
i just actually update up of mine to 18
two weeks ago so i was doing 15 with the
18
i don't remember her percentage because
she with her income she doesn't make as
much that we've dropped down hurts a
little bit
well i'll tell you i'll tell you this
much our plan works every time you work
it and so if you want to do our plan you
want to retire with dignity i would tell
you to drop that back down to 15 use the
extra 3
that's going towards the mortgage that
needs to be the focus for the next you
know 3 4 5 years i want to see this
thing gone so that you can go i see the
light at the end of the tunnel i've
worked my whole life for this moment and
we can actually retire with the money in
our investments instead of go well
we've got a mortgage payment still
and we don't have enough in our
investments to to make it
right and that was going to be my next
question i'm glad you brought that up
because i was just going to say should i
drop it down some and put the extra to
it to the mortgage yeah so should i go
below to 15. like go down to 10 or just
no no stay 15 on the dot with your
household income and then once you pay
off the house hey you can go buck wild
you can increase that
right yeah and that and that's what
you're going to be able to do because
guess what when you don't have a
mortgage payment you can invest a
mortgage payment and you start doing
that even for five 10 years and you let
that grow over the next 20 30 years of
your life man you guys are going to be
in good shape you're going to be able to
leave a legacy you got kids
oh yeah we do we have four kids yeah
grandkids everything wow
man well i'm pumped for you guys but
stay the course uh don't try to do
todd's plan i'm telling you this stuff
works every time you work it we've had
tens of millions of people do this stuff
and if you follow it to a t it will lead
you to where you want to go to that
dream retirement
well that's why we're on it all right
well thanks a lot for your help i
appreciate it absolutely todd thank you
so much for the call y'all
good stuff there ken yeah he's doing
great you just sometimes you got to get
a real readjustment he's doing very well
but george i liked it
it was it was a little bit of snark
which is you know for you you really had
to restrain yourself for the course for
me but i think i think the big takeaway
is is if you want to work todd's plan
you can but it doesn't work like the
ramsey plan well everyone thinks they're
special and they're unique and like oh
here's why here's why here's why there's
a reason why we why we drill the baby
steps down because it's
data driven
to the tune of millions and millions and
millions and millions of people
including the two people that are on the
debt-free stage that we're gonna talk to
i can't wait let's get to that hey open
phones this hour triple eight eight two
five five two two five this is the
ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're not using puretalk for your
wireless you're paying too much puretalk
gives you the same great 5g coverage on
the same 5g network as one of the big
guys for half the cost the average
family saves over 800 a year go to
puretalk.com and choose the affordable
plan that's right for you with their
30-day risk-free guarantee you have
nothing to lose go to puretalk.com and
enter the promo code ramsey to save 50
off your first month
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i'm george campbell ramsey personality
joined by ken coleman this is the ramsay
show
and in the lobby of ramsey solutions on
the debt-free stage brian and angela
join us hey guys what's up
hey how's it going hi guys great where
are you from minnesota southern part of
minnesota oh i love the accent all the
way here to do a debt-free scream okay
how much have you guys paid off
98
500.
wow all right how long did that take 22
months whoa okay and what was your range
of income during that time 136 up to
145.
nice what do you guys do for a living i
am a general manager of a hotel
and i do auto body fantastic good stuff
there okay so what type of debt was this
98.5
oh it's a little bit of everything
uh auto loans uh
personal loan medical bills and then the
big one credit cards yeah
what was the biggest debt out of all
that
it was probably a a credit card credit
cards yeah so we were having some fun we
were on a spending spree for a little
while yeah we weren't being intentional
at all okay but then 22 months ago
something shifted because you guys went
hard at this debt what happened
well go ahead
um he brought home fpu
dvds from a co-worker
and they sat on our dresser for a couple
months
okay so i got to ask a detail was this a
passive move
uh brian where you just put it on the
dresser and waited for her to address it
or did you bring it up and she was just
like that's nice and we ignored it
the latter
okay all right all right
so we took a road trip and we had about
three hours in the car and we talked
about it and realized well we've got to
do something
we listened to
dave on the podcast and
started talking about it and realized we
got to do something and
i kind of dug my heels in i said this
isn't going to work it's not going to
work why just because it was going to
work so much debt and so much you know
we were paying
robbing peter to pay paul and just you
know doing all kinds of things and it
just was came each month and it was like
we were we were
you know dying so you just had no hope
that this plan was even going to work no
no so we put it together we did the
the baby steps and the first two two
debts we paid off and it was like okay
this is working we can do this and then
we kept piling on that extra money to
the next debt and then it was like the
chains were loosening on our necks oh
how quickly did you pay off those first
two once you started how what was the
time period i think the first couple
little ones was like a couple months and
then we realized wow this is wasted
momentum yes
wow and you decided you know what i can
see some light at the end of the tunnel
let's go all in on this thing yeah we
were selling stuff and
um
it just
it took off wow what was the the most
you made off the sale what'd you sell
well um
we did a lot of things we walked around
the farm place and just put stuff on
craigslist and and realized okay we're
making a little extra money here and we
both got extra jobs um that helped a lot
working overtime he did and and i had
night jobs after my full-time jobs wow
wow we guys went all in even with the
kiddos you guys decided we're going to
sacrifice for a short period of time
so that we can leave a legacy so that we
can have this freedom what was the extra
jobs um i worked at a restaurant and
also a brewery wow
nice you guys were willing to do
whatever it took
yeah whatever you sold so much stuff the
kids thought they were next yeah don't
look at me mom don't look at me i'm not
for sale
oh my goodness wow and now here you are
to do your debt free scream how does it
feel to be completely debt-free it feels
wonderful believable
unbelievable
there's emotion there what's driving
that emotion for you angela just being
here this whole this whole place yeah um
it's safe and hard it saved our marriage
oh wow that's great and our future yeah
tell us about that what was the
relationship between getting out of debt
and your marriage improving oh it
brought more communication
and uh
sitting down together yes
each week
going through what we needed to do for
our budget and being intentional and
having that communication
it was the first time you've done that
in a long time it sounds correct that
was big wow
i want to ask you guys something on this
marriage issue i'm just curious
did you find that there was stress
on both of you
that you were unaware of that was
causing maybe some marital strife that
once you started making momentum and
feeling hope relieving the stress
that that led to a stronger relationship
or was it just that we sat down and
started communicating but i'm just
curious i've never asked a married
couple this oh it was both it was both
there was that stress that we were both
feeling but we weren't communicating
about it yeah yeah and when we came
together it was like right
it's like you have two people that are
cranky pants you're not quite sure why
we're both cranky pains right yeah right
yeah yeah yeah yep
you've done this stuff and i want you to
talk to that person who felt like you
did when you started you went there's no
way this plan is going to work we have
too much debt that might work for them
but it's not going to work for me what
do you tell that person the key to
getting out of debt is
be intentional
yes and you have to be on the same page
and know know to
trust the process
trust the process that there is the
steps are simple
it's simple just follow those steps
and be patient
and know that
in the long run you're going to feel
like we do right now wow yeah it's it's
i'm totally grateful and thankful for
everything that ramsey solutions has
done for us yeah and we were able to do
this process with god guiding us through
this whole thing
he had a hand in everything
amen
wow so did you guys have cheerleaders
along the way we did oh yeah who were
they well our kids were big teammates
helped us through this whole thing by
babysitting and helping out around the
house so mom and dad could work
and then one of our biggest cheerleaders
was my mom who we brought here today
that's amazing
and look at look what happens when you
do that to the kids they turn into
adults they do it's amazing when you put
some responsibility on them they see mom
and dad sacrificing yeah that's what's
uh i'm just asking uh and nothing
against the two boys uh blake and
brecken but was ava kind of in charge
when you guys were pulling the overtime
she said she kept the house going she
did how old is ava ava's 14. oh i had a
girl there we go she was in charge she's
like i got this
wow very nice yeah that's great so how's
it feel to be completely dead free now
it feels awesome amazing
amazing well i hope everyone listening
watching can see the emotion feel the
emotion of of what that levity looks
like when you get rid of the chains when
you get rid of the payments in your life
what you are able to accomplish and what
it does to you not just financially but
emotionally and mentally and spiritually
that's right
well let's get the you got the whole
family let's bring them up here tell us
the names and ages
we got ava she's 14
and we have blake
he is 11
and we have brecken is eight oh i love
it and if you're not watching you gotta
know they've got the matching t-shirts
to say better than i deserve weird
people gazelle intense and that's
exactly what you guys have been we'll
continue to be and we're so proud of you
you guys are amazing thank you thank you
and i'm guessing you've been practicing
the debt-free scream all the kids oh
yeah oh yeah okay i want to hear it loud
and proud for all the times that your
mom and dad have told you to be quiet
kids this is the moment where you get
mom and dad back i get to use the
outdoor voice indoors this is special
well we've got a copy of babysit
millionaires for you dave's number one
best-selling book that is the next
chapter for you guys that's the legacy
that you get to leave because of the
hard work that you've done and will
continue to do and we also have a copy
of the total money makeover so you can
give it to someone else and kick start
their journey and it might sit on their
dresser for a little while but man the
life change that could happen from
something like that is just amazing
all right thank you let's do this thing
we've got brian and angela and ava and
blake and brecken minneapolis minnesota
98 500 paid off in 22 months making 136
up to 145 selling everything they could
working extra doing whatever it took
count it down let's hear a debt-free
scream three
two one
[Applause]
just seeing a family tree change like
that yeah that makes your day you know i
got to tell you mom's emotion
a sense of relief
a sense of hope about their future it's
so awesome
yes that's peace i want that for every
single person listening you can do this
okay brian and angela did it and you're
no different you're not special you can
do this plan this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Applause]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm
george campbell joined today by ramsay
personality ken coleman we are taking
your calls on life money career you name
it we are here for you triple eight
eight two five five two two five is the
number to call
janet joins us up next in kansas city
janet welcome to the ramsay show
hi how are you guys doing great how can
ken and i help
well thanks for taking my call
i'm looking to make a career change and
i
have a background in sales i'm currently
a bereavement coordinator for a hospice
company
and so it's been hard to make that
switch i've been doing this for a while
and i think when potential employee
employers see my resume they're thinking
wow she's been out of sales for a while
and she's a grief counselor
um so i've kind of hit a rock wall i've
been putting in for many jobs
and i just i kind of want your advice on
what you would recommend for me so uh a
follow-up question janet is when you're
putting in for all these jobs describe
the process what tell me what that
involves you doing what just submitting
an online resume
what else what else what else
right
i'm sure my resume really needs to be
updated because it probably highlights
my age i have a lot of experience and
that's
all documented but
i go to indeed i go to
you know career
sites linkedin
so you're supporting everything online
right
yes okay so i want to encourage you
because i think you're discouraged
and you should not be discouraged
so the good news is you should not be
discouraged the bad news is you've been
doing it all wrong which is why you
shouldn't be discouraged because i'm
going to tell you how to do it right
this is not a you problem this is a this
is the way you're going about it does
that encourage you
it does all right so listen first things
first
um we're gonna get you uh the free
resume guide uh at kencoleman.com i'll
make sure kelly gets you a link to that
and we can get you to that and it's
gonna help you actually restructure your
resume so that looks better but even
then that's not enough that's not enough
because i read some data recently that
over a million
qualified candidates janet
that's you
over a million
qualified candidates in 2021 never even
got looked at because of the
artificial intelligence the online
software that everybody's using that
you've been submitting your resume to
and many times if there's just one
keyword that's wrong or there's one
thing in your description of your
experience
these artificial intelligence softwares
will kick you out do you understand what
i'm saying
yeah so it is a very good possibility
especially when you're not getting any
calls back and i'm just curious how many
times are you not even getting a
response
well probably 90 percent of the time i
mean i have gotten some some calls and
you know maybe a first interview and
then that's it like a phone interview
all right so here's the thing um and
actually i won't even have kelly do this
because you can do this because that's
all kelly could do for you i want you to
go to kencoleman.com
it's ramsey solutions
and i just want you to download the
resume guide and the interview guide
okay how to win the interview
and and the resume guide as well and
it's going to help you
with a real template
show you how to do it why to do it that
way secondly it's going to help you
prepare for the interview so you can win
your interviews but i got one other gift
for you i'm going to give you a copy of
my number one bestselling book the
proximity principle because this is
what's missing this is the real
ingredient that you're missing and the
proximity principle janet says this it's
very simple thought in order to do what
you want to do sales
you got to be around people that are
doing it
and in places where it is happening
people and places people the right
people plus the right places equals
opportunities for janet where the door
swings open for janet she's not having
to kick it down george people are going
to come to her so janna what that means
to you is you got to start connecting
through
one-to-one relationships that you have
and then
the next level connections where maybe
it's a friend of yours or a friend of
your friend or it is a acquaintance that
you haven't talked in a while but
they're friendly and and they've got
connections to sales jobs or they are in
sales and you're beginning to rub
shoulders if you will and you're talking
to people that are successful sales
people who might be aware of a position
that's open because here's janet the
reality you are smack dab in the middle
of the hottest job market in the history
of this country
it's never been hotter it's never been
easier
in the sense of
people are looking for sales people and
just because
you
haven't done sales in a long time
doesn't mean you forgot how to sell true
or false
true all right so i here's what i want
i'm giving you a lot of stuff that you
have to do but i want you to read the
proximity principle there's five
specific people and five places we
unpack in that book but since you know
what you want to do it's just all a
function of how do you get there and i
want you to do the deep dive it's an
easy read
but i want you to your homework
assignment today
is you've got to start telling everybody
you know i mean social media i mean
people get a church with people you work
out with people you you know that you
see at social clubs tell them you're
looking for sales you've got sales
experience who's hiring in sales and
then go back to your target list some of
the places where you applied before but
you never even got
a technology response much less a call
you're not done with those places i'll
bet they don't even know about you janet
and so i want you to work this process
who do you know that knows somebody that
works over at all those companies and
george here's what i know
she will get an opportunity but that's
how you do it it is a
it is a dogged pursuit yeah you just
keep going well as you were talking
about that i thought about my own career
journey and got a great story i lived
the proximity principle before i even
knew it existed yeah and that's how i
got the role here at ramsey it wasn't
because of my amazing experience it was
because of who i knew how was this how i
was connected and my pursuit of that
role and the value i could bring yeah
and i think it wasn't because of your
resume either no you you actually we
really worked your personal
relationships to get in the door here
and then the resume was something that
like oh well here's a george resume but
but they knew about you
through a relationship yes that's what
got you the energy and i think what
janet's feeling is well it's because of
my age it's because my lack of
experience and i i think that can that
can just well it destroys you up pretty
quick and so i love the encouragement
hey it's neither of those things it's
not you just need to get connected she
hasn't been noticed
see in order to get hired you first have
to get noticed
and then when you get noticed there's
your opportunity to stand out and i
think a lot of people get beat down and
here's here's one thing i really want to
encourage this audience with because we
have a lot of people george who are
trying to get out of debt
and they listen to these debt-free
screamers and they go every time we talk
to these folks
almost every time i'd have to have i'd
have to talk to james about this and get
it i bet there's a master spreadsheet
but i don't recall ever being on this
show
and talking to debt-free screamers where
their income did not go up during the
journey they were focused and so some of
you are just going i want to make more
money i want to get a better job just to
get out of debt but i feel discouraged
well you shouldn't be discouraged here's
the deal you think that submitting a
bunch of resumes online and sending 27
emails on linkedin
is good activity and so you sit back and
you go well i sent 27 emails on linkedin
let me just sit here and wait for people
to show up and give me an opportunity
guess what folks it doesn't work that
way that is activity but it's the wrong
activity it's one step of the process
but we can't just end there
relationships
relationships
and relationships the top three ways to
get a better job
those are it all the same by the way and
the data backs it up it was a long time
sociology study by a guy named mark
granovetter who found that most people
get jobs through what he called loose
ties that's fancy sociology speak what
he meant was acquaintances
you are sitting in the bleachers with
parents of your of your kids teammates
they may be the next job
absolutely and some of our best hires we
made here at ramsey is referrals and so
we get those all the time it's not
because they made it through the stack
of resumes it's because i knew ken ken
knew me he knew my skill set and he went
hey george would be a great hire we got
to get him in the door and put him at
the top of the stack that's what you
just described is beautiful that's how
you come out of the pile and go to the
top of the stack because by the way they
know stack anymore no but it is digital
it's a robot spewing it back out you may
never even get noticed if you're playing
the lottery like janet's been playing
the lottery or the slot machine yeah we
got to do better than that so hang on
the line janet uh we'll get you the
proximity principle then go to
kencoma.com for those free resources the
interview guide and how to win the
interview i mean the resume guide and
how to win the interview good stuff
there ken some encouragement for your
career and your money that's what we're
here for that puts this hour of the
ramsay show in the books we'll be back
with you before we know it this is the
ramsay show
[Music]
hey folks ken coleman here did you know
the ramsay show is one of the most
popular podcasts in the world it's your
daily dose of advice on life and money
check out all of our shows from the
ramsey network wherever you listen to
podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsay show where
america hangs out to have a conversation
about your life your money your career
your relationships and everything else
i'm george campbell your host joined
today by my friend ken coleman and we
are taking your calls the number to call
is triple eight eight two five
five two two five if you need some
confirmation some affirmation
maybe there's a job change you're not
loving your career you're not sure where
to store the emergency fund you name it
we'll try to help ken we will try our
best yeah yeah yeah sure but we're gonna
be able to help we've got we've got
proven more confident clear paths
full of principles that if you do it it
works well i was just throwing a little
extra confidence i was alluding to the
fact that we've got opinions and we're
experts on our opinion well that's true
there we go that's absolutely true
george well people are doing it jt is on
the line to kick off this hour and st
louis jt welcome to the show
hey guys thanks for taking my call
absolutely how can can i help
okay uh let me start by saying i'm
getting ready to do something i don't
want to do but i'm also going off for
the mantra uh happy wife
happy life oh boy oh that's a setup
boy oh boy jt that's one of the better
setups i've ever heard i can't wait to
hear what this thing is you're about to
do because your wife is making you
go jt
um just a preference
we are debt-free we paid off our
mortgage and all our bills baby step
seven
yes wow way to go man
thank you thank you we just haven't made
our way east to do the uh decree screams
but i'm i'm dying to do it uh so i
promised my wife a car
or a jeep she found one
um you know they're very hard to find
apparently she found the one color that
is like you could never find so we've
got about 37 000 in savings which um
that is our emergency fund but also our
car funds uh-oh um apparently uh jeep's
coming in in two weeks i got a pretty
good price but
we're going to be about 15 000
shorts
hold on
hold on hold on i got to get some
details i don't want to interrupt this
momentum here
37 000
and that's and you're going to be 15
short so you're telling me 52 000 for
this jeep that only comes in this one
color and leaves you with zero dollars
well i still want to keep some money in
the emergency fund so the price is 41
000. oh okay it's only slightly slightly
better than what i described exactly
what's the color of the jeep i gotta
know
okay it's uh it's a word i've never
heard before called snozberry oh jesus
you're joking someone made that how do
you spell that is this a prank call
apparently it's a dark red
i'm looking it up okay it's a dark red
jeep the same james this is from willy
wonka in the chocolate factory yes
okay
this is a thing though that jeep is
marketing and it's got jt's wife on the
hook man all right jt all right so
what's the problem you're about ready to
do you said i'm about ready to do
something bad i think that's i think we
all know what it is
we've went through our bank and
i can get a loan um
the maximum would be about five months
and they're fine with that the minimum i
would have to take out as ten thousand
and we literally save anywhere between
seven and eight thousand per month
so i we can really pay this off in three
to four months max if you can pay it off
in three to four months then you can
save it up in three to four
months i agree but
the cars should be coming in in about
two weeks well wait a second is it the
only what's the name of it a snoz
is it the only snozberry jeep in the
entire united states
on the show today i never thought i'd
say that you have tried apparently we've
tried
no no no
[Music]
we haven't tried sounds like mama has
tried and you're just being made you're
being made aware of all of this is this
breaking news to you jt
uh
as of four days ago yes
i i thought i heard that when you said
it's on the way did she already commit
to this
no uh we did put a deposit down of 500
they wanted 2 000. i said no way 500 is
it refundable
uh no it's well here's the deal jt you
paid a 500 stupid tax
and we're not getting that car i'm gonna
research george please straighten jt i'm
going to research snozzberry jeeps right
now please do i don't believe it's the
only one in the united states here's the
thing jt number one your emergency fund
and your car fund need to be separate
yes because as you can see this is what
happens when you combine them it becomes
well it's a squishy fun for the car
slash emerge this is not an emergency
so separate this out three to six months
of expenses what does that look like for
you guys
uh six months would be right around
seven thousand dollars
seven thousand you're a month
no no no total you're saying six months
of expenses for you guys is seven
thousand dollars total
yes
we have no car payments we have no debt
whatsoever even just insurance premiums
sinking fund i mean you name it it's got
to be more than that food gas
oh yeah yeah yeah i'm just talking those
no so let's uh
sell probably about 25 000. okay that's
a very different number than seven okay
so let's say 25 000 is our magic
emergency fund number that means we have
12 000 to put towards the car okay
yes this is reality so 12 000 and we
need 41 to get this jeep
so what does that tell you we are short
about 29 000 right
correct so the question becomes how
quickly can we save up 29 000
and then we go jeep shopping
you told me you could save six seven
thousand a month
yes
okay so then we're doing some more math
here and going okay in about four months
or less
we can have this jeep and you can it's
going to take that much time to see it
seems like to order another one
well that's what i'm hoping is that
right now it's due to be in in two to
three weeks but they said that it could
be two two to three months
so let's head into two to three months
and
your wife has car fever and she needs to
freaking chill man
here's the only question i have jt
you guys walk the baby steps out how
long you been following dave ramsey and
ramsay solutions i'm just curious
three years three years was she all in
on this process she was eighty percent
okay
all right and so now all of a sudden
she's like well we can wiggle so did you
let me ask you this when you called us
by the way it's a good thing dave's not
in today no the call wouldn't have
lasted this long what did you think we
were going to say
um i just
because it's such a short loan and we've
got very stable jobs and we make about
240 a year
i knew you wouldn't say yes
how about this i'll give you a dave
quote since he's not here oh i like it
adults devise a plan and follow it
children do what feels good which you
did
you did devise a plan and follow it and
here's the deal you guys make enough
money to where you're going to just have
to all right so
here's what i would do if i were you jt
i'm co-hosting today so george is the
money expert but i'm just going to lay
it out there's a guy who's been married
almost 24 years this is a marriage
conversation yeah this is not you're
you're posing this as a
as a
automobile conversation you got to say
hey no we make enough money to save up
there'll be another snozberry jeep we
can order this is a benjamin button
situation she's reverting back to child
like form okay we can't let this happen
at all we cannot let this happen jt the
snozzberry can wait by the way is the
first and last time i'll ever say that i
do want to say jt thank you for the
question because i never even knew what
snozzberry is i'm looking up a suit
right now it's literally just maroon
it's a maroon jeep who cares there's
more maroon jeeps out there in the world
snuzberry
i'm exhausted this is the ramsay show
[Music]
if you're considering a career in
technology i recommend bethel tech and
i'm not alone here's what brendan said
before bethel tech i was driving uber
within four months of graduating i got a
job paying sixty thousand dollars about
two years after that i got a remote job
that pays me a hundred and thirty
thousand dollars all thanks to what i
learned at bethel tech you could be next
get started today at betheltech.net
and get one thousand to twenty five
hundred dollars off of your tuition
again it's betheltech.net
ken coleman
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm
george campbell ramsey personality and
host of the fine print joined today by
ken coleman host of the ken coleman show
aptly named and we are taking your calls
triple eight eight two five five two two
five
is the number to call
all right ken this is big
you are in the career space workspace
baby we're talking about winning at work
and here's the deal with work
when you work with people they're called
co-workers and sometimes
they can drive you crazy oh and
sometimes you drive your co-workers
crazy do you even know it if you don't
think you have crazy co-workers you're
the crazy that's a great point you might
be it and so we've got a list here of
some common things that you might do
that might be driving your coworkers
crazy yeah
or if you're wondering why you want to
switch jobs
these
annoying
habits
may be trying to drive that you think
you want to change careers and you just
need a new location because you work
with people that's right you want to
jump off of a cliff and here's the thing
so we got a list caveat this it can be
really difficult to approach a co-worker
when they're bothering you something
because you don't want to start the
conflict and go hey ken you got to stop
clipping your toes you know what i like
maybe we'll address how you would
approach some of these but let's let's
dive in here okay um uh how about the
person who uh
who walks through the office or sits
near you
and they hum or see the hummer the
hummer or the singer yeah out of nowhere
you they bring you into a song they've
got a song in their heart and they want
everyone to know and by the way have you
ever noticed that these people james
they never start at the start of the
song it's always like the song's going
in their head and they just kind of pick
it up mid-verse and we're all left to go
what what's happening here they hit the
chorus these people that they oh uh
james brought up one the whistler
oh man the whistle while you work we
don't want nobody likes a whistler
that's nails on a chalkboard
but see i think it's all the same the
singer the people who are humming all
the time it's a lack of self-awareness
is what it is yeah i don't want to be
brought into your personal soundtrack
that's a good good line right there okay
how about this one ken people who listen
to music without headphones
because their playlists are so good yeah
yeah put some headphones on and you know
what secondary on airplanes
put some headphones on yeah if you're in
any public space
put some headphones on it's 20 22.
they're cheap i always love the old dude
on the airplane who forgets about the
concept of the headphones and he starts
the movie and it's so loud because he's
deaf anyway that we hear it all the way
in the back of the airplane yikes yeah
headphones are good
all right next up uh okay
here's my how about the people that
reply all to emails when they shouldn't
oh or they don't reply all when they
should in other words
they just don't have any common sense
around emails the kids call that cringe
is that what they call yeah cringe
here's the one that drives me nuts
uh james was talking to me about this
and he's right
how about the person who replies with
emojis all the time or gifts yeah do you
call them gifts or gym i'm a gift guy
her jiff in the control room gif i like
a well-placed gif but it's the people
who just only reply in them and you
can't get an actual answer out of them
yeah they have nothing to say right it's
like they're a puppet they won't be real
for any moment of time and yeah i tell
you the one that drives me is the last
word person they always got to get the
last word no it's clear that the email
chain is done we've resolved our
business and they gotta fire one more
unnecessary thx exclamation point like
we all need one more email what i love
is they didn't have the time to just do
the a-n-k right but they had time to
send one more meaningless email
here's the deal nobody ever needs to do
the unnecessary thank you less emails in
2022. what else you got george this one
gets me because i'm guilty holding a
door for you when you're too far away
and so you feel like you have to run
because the person's just standing there
waiting for you yes okay and by the way
if you ever notice that person has
always got this big smile on their face
like they're doing you a big favor right
like you're incapable of opening the
door i know you're a long way away but
i'm such a stellar human being that i'm
going to hold this right and it has the
opposite effect doesn't it what does it
do to you when you see that door open
from that far away it feels like my
middle school soccer coach going let's
see some hustle camel come on
let's go pick them up pick them up right
it's very frustrating so here's my
parameter ken either you've got to be
holding things to where you can't open
the door and then i'm happy to open it
you're right if you're holding a bunch
of stuff i feel bad i'll hold it for 15
30 seconds and if you're 10 feet away i
go all right that's the parameter if
you're more than 10 feet
just be on your way i'll open the door
myself yeah you're not a big jerk yeah
yeah i'll be kind we're not saying don't
be kind but don't make it awkward all
right george moving on here's one that i
think the whole world at work can
sympathize with and that is
the disgusting
awful grotesque food that stinks up the
entire floor not just the break room or
the kitchen i mean it seeps throughout
the entire building hey no one should
ever eat fish at work ever
ever it's a dangerous mood i don't even
care if it's fish sticks from long john
silvers no fish people are getting fish
sticks
on silvers is that still somebody's got
fast fast food we got a list here in
case you're wondering what are those
other foods we got fish we got
sauerkraut brussels sprouts by the way
chicken gizzard no one's eating chicken
for lunch
oh james is pointing to someone in the
control room well someone who is someone
who had that experience not that did it
oh so somebody on our team which shall
remain nameless brought chicken gizzard
which by the way i didn't even know what
chicken gizzard is i don't know where to
buy that it was at a previous job so
thankfully it's no one here oh thank you
for the caveat john's clear don't want
to offend anybody here at ramsey
solutions what is gizzard am i allowed
to ask that is that
it's a part of a chicken i never want to
touch or eat
that's it hey here's a general rule of
thumb if you don't know what part of the
animal it comes off of you might not eat
it
is that fair hey i want to go back a
step brussels sprouts is on my top three
awful smells of all time wow
okay so save it do it at home
good job yeah not eating around can now
i will say we've got a cafeteria here at
ramsey solutions so there's a lot more
places for the smells to go it's a big
open area back in the old days we had
tiny you know the tiny little kitchens
and break rooms not a lot of place for
the smell to go so be kind who's up next
on the list is it you or me i think it's
me oh yeah i was talking about the awful
smells i'm gonna put this one out there
okay
sales folks who talk very loudly oh on
the on the floor
when you because you've got that this
world-class technology a lot of the
salespeople wearing these kind of deals
right not quite as big a mic and then
they got to go over the top 17 people
all talking with their outdoor voices a
lot of fake laughs too
sales people best fake laughers all time
oh yeah they'll laugh at anything laugh
at anything give you a and by the way
not just a laugh a guffaw you know what
a guffaw is that's a
leave it to ken for a ten dollar word
for laugh gefa is like a chesty laugh
right we're we're heaving a lot of
volume a lot of shaking you're are you a
gaffare no okay hurts yeah it's not
healthy for you okay here's one how
about uh how about booking a meeting
room
uh that could fit 30 people when there's
three people that one is hilarious to
walk by it's kind of obnoxious yeah
where do we sit there's too many
decisions i have to make prior to the
meeting that's true there's plenty of
meeting rooms around here yeah yeah yeah
yeah uh now a few things that didn't
make this list this was kind of compiled
by some uh
the conference call etiquette you know
the zoom like like so when the pandemic
hit like everybody was on zoom or
whatever your platform is for video
calls
drives me nuts you got romper room going
around in the back right a lot of
distractions i don't want to be into
your life you have invited me into your
life what we're supposed to be doing is
having a meeting is the blur feature
where it blurs the background see i
didn't even know that existed it does
because here's what i do ken i'm judging
everything in their house i'm going oh
wow that's so true
how am i supposed to pay attention when
you've invited me into your life it's
too much for me i can't i can't i can't
process it yeah i hate meetings anyway
just as a general rule i walk into
meetings going i hate this and then i
hope it's good i just hate the
unnecessary meetings our friend patrick
lencione he's got the book death by
meeting it's a great book and so the
meetings that could have been an email
sometimes people just want to hear
themselves talk in the room
and that's why we go let's let's circle
up let's meet we'll circle back
circle by circling see now you're going
into a potential another list that's for
another day and that's overused office
jargon well you know what i'm talking
about where people just wear it out
circle back is a big one yeah another
one is i don't have a bandwidth
bandwidth bandwidth
band
from all jargon band bandwidth yeah
there it is
hey if you are doing any of those things
you need to stop it immediately this is
the takeaway yeah because you are the
annoying obnoxious person and know what
he wants to be around so you know we all
have room for growth ken has called you
guys out now luckily we work with a lot
of great folks at ramsey solutions this
stuff happens very sparingly james only
does about two of those this is james's
personal list of things that
you bother him i do yeah this was jesus
an email from james going ken i'd really
like you to improve in these series good
stuff
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm
george campbell joined today by ken
coleman and in the lobby of ramsey
solutions on the debt-free stage we've
got marzo and rosa how are you guys good
good good where are you guys from we're
from the dallas area a small town called
carrollton texas awesome yes i know of
carrollton all right how much have you
guys paid off we paid off 46
177
and 43 cents wow okay 10 months 10
months and what was your range of income
during that time
it was about
65 000 and
now we're at about 90. whoa
way to go what do you guys do for a
living i work in accounts payable for a
big um chain of family restaurants
entertainment restaurants and i work for
uh ups at the warehouse very nice i've
been there for 20 years all right
yeah okay so tell us about this debt
what made up the forty six thousand one
hundred seventy seven and forty three
cents okay we had a uh of course we had
to buy a swing set for our boys um and
we put that on the credit card sure
and um we also had my student loans and
from my uh one of my master's degrees
and then um
we had
a van uh the van the minivan
a car loan so we have the credit card
student loans we also had a personal
loan that we found out a bit after we
thought we were done you found out
we forgot well
going way back to when we first got
married and we got our first home
my mom um did
help us right by letting us borrow um to
help us with the down payment and we
only had like a thousand and she gave
she
lent us about three thousand and we
hadn't helped we hadn't paid it off
apparently and you just forgot we did
yeah because it was my mom you know
wow i know i should have been more
responsible i wasn't
mom's paid back now
she is okay so 10 months that's a fast
journey what happened 10 months ago
where you said no more
well
honestly it's weird how god works in
mysterious ways but um i was actually
looking for a podcast
that would help us with our
teenager that we were kind of struggling
with parenting and all of that and you
know he he we came i came across um dr
meg meeker and um in one of her
commercial breaks i think it was the
dave ramsey show so i was like i've
heard of him before but what is he about
and you know of course it um i looked
him up and i started listening to the
podcast and certain things just started
to click and i shared with him and i
said yeah you should start listening to
it too and i played a few clips of it
for him and he was in on it right away i
downloaded everything and
we started listening to it and we were
in and
we just sat down and um you know it
actually it it was so difficult because
i had just
left teaching um
but then
i had jobs that were not really
permanent they were through like
agencies and so um but we were still
doing really bad financial things like
putting you know the swing set on a
credit card
and um
and then
i
i got
several jobs um but once we we got the
ball rolling with all of this we
i said you know what we don't want to
pay uh you know we don't want to take
five years to pay the minivan i i want
to pay it off asap so
it all happened during the pandemic
and what was what was easy for us to
realize was that we were spending so
much money eating out when i was
teaching because we made a lot of money
you know so why not we could spend it
definitely that was
for me i think the pandemic was the
blessing the blessing to start
knowing that we were spending a lot of
money it caused you to pay attention for
once exactly so
at that moment when the pandemi when the
pandemic started
we decided to
cut a lot of
spend expenses that we were doing for
like example going out to eat every
weekend
going to the movies every weekend we
were spending like maybe 15 to 1600
every month on
going out just having a good time yes
just having a good time that was more
than our mortgage payment oh my goodness
wow
that was your realization honestly and
really the pandemic actually helped us
do that because we couldn't really go
out and go to the movies and go too you
know so um but yeah and of course the
the stimis did help with with that to
help us pay off stuff but um
but i you know i'm a really i'm a
hustler and um not that he's not he is
um he's been there for 20 years but um i
was like you know what i'm gonna go do
uber while you while you um are at work
in the evenings and um i drove the kids
around i drove you know my mom was in
the car with me just like you can keep
them in the car and i will um i'll stay
in the car with them and you'd go down
and deliver that food and make that
money and so um i was making myself a
goal of every week what i was going to
pay down with the money i was making
with ubereats i
taught online um esl and then um what
other jobs did i have i forgot
um
oh i was a tax preparer yes i was a tax
preparer immigration staff
yeah helping people with uh mary poppins
of side hustles what was the most
lucrative side hustle what were you
making um
i think uh tax preparing um just because
all of this uh debt-free journey the end
result and just by the grace of god
we've been able to cash flow the
beginning of my business which is it's a
multi-services now so
yeah and in this year so good for you so
what would you tell people is the key to
getting out of that uh well to me the
key
is definitely the
having a budget
to sit down and write the numbers yeah
because that's when you know exactly
where you where your money goes
and that's how you can have the real
control
of your money no money no no it doesn't
matter how much money you make but if
you have the control of your money you
will be
you're going to have a future better
future yeah and what matters is what you
do with the money
so
i agree i think that uh writing the
numbers down and using that every dollar
app really helped us know okay we're
going to assign every single dollar a
name a category and um i feel like
that's what may makes you realize where
like i said where your money's going
where do you want it to go where do you
want it to go yeah you guys just needed
a plan and some focus i mean you were
just kind of floating around spending
not knowing what was going on you know
what we realized that we were actually
dave ish before before we even knew
about dave um we had done a few things
like we did create a an emergency fund
which of course it wasn't an emergency
but
we were like oh let's finish paying off
you know the 529 for our 18 year old
since he's about to go to college so we
paid about 21 000
um that was left for that to pay that
off um and that was not part of the
debt-free journey that we mentioned
earlier so it was technically over you
know over 60 000 but um but we did that
before coming across dave and we're like
wait we did that all the wrong way
everything's out of order yeah out of
order but now we're we're on the right
path yeah we're so proud of you guys
so much we're on baby step six and um if
you know god i know we're gonna know
god's gonna help us and um our goal is
to pay off our um a hundred and fifty
thousand dollar um home loan in about
five years good wow great job well you
were on that path and you got you
brought all the family with you we
bought our three boys you want to get
them on up here what are their names and
ages so this one is sebastian or
sebastian and he is six years old and
this is abdiel he's
three and they've been practicing their
scream and this is um harrett or jarrett
who is 18.
beautiful family thank you and here we
are all debt-free with the matching
t-shirts i love a good matching t-shirt
who doesn't this is incredible all right
so you've been practicing which is
exciting we've got a copy of dave's baby
step millionaire's book and you get the
back says the borrower's slave to the
lender that's fantastic so that's your
next chapter is to become millionaires
to pay off that house following the baby
steps we're so excited for you and we're
going to give you a copy of the total
money makeover to start someone else's
journey great debt thank you i love it
all right here we go we got marzo and
rosa and jared and sebastian and abdiel
from the dallas texas area 46 000 paid
off in 10 months making 65 all the way
up to 90 with some side hustles and
everything you can imagine getting
thrown at it count it down let's hear a
debt free scream ready boys
three
two one
we are dead
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
way to go guys that was cute yes the
little man uh wins the cute award though
that was fun
i love to see that those kids are never
gonna be the same that's right because
of those parents sacrifice that's what
this is all about this is the ramsay
show
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm
george campbell joined today by ken
coleman
well folks if you've been watching the
news or breathing at all the housing
market is really hot and so your house
could be worth a lot more today than it
was when you bought it and that also
means your old insurance policy might
not give you enough coverage anymore and
what's the point of paying for insurance
that won't swing the cost to repair or
rebuild your home now some policies will
automatically raise your coverage to
cover rising home prices or material
costs but not all of them so if your
home's value has gone up or it's been
over a year since you checked your
homeowner's policy you've got to talk to
one of our endorsed local providers in
your area our elps are independent
agents who will compare multiple
policies to find the best coverage for
your home and your budget
that's why they're ramsey trusted
because they'll put you first period go
to ramseysolutions.com home to talk with
a trusted home insurance pro today
that's ramseysolutions.com
our question of the day comes from
blinds.com find out for yourself why
they are the number one online retailer
of custom window coverings you get free
samples free shipping and with the new
promos they run every single month you
can save even more you can use the promo
code ramsey to get the best deal today's
question comes from drew in north
carolina i'm a senior leader at a large
company and due to some issues in my
area i need to move on before i become
jaded in my position you don't just give
two weeks notice and walk out the door
so i am in the middle of a month-long
handoff of my responsibilities my
challenge is
that my employees are also starting to
question the culture and financial
insolvency
i don't think it's ethical to lie to
them and tell them to hang in there but
i also
don't want to be viewed as planting
toxic seeds on my way out i truly truly
believe in my depart excuse me i truly
believe that my department will be shut
down this year
should i be honest with them
about why i'm leaving
or
try to stay neutral and say something
like you are very observant and you need
to make a decision based on what you see
this is it this feels very complex and
it's not
many times
the best way out of complexity is
simplicity and
i don't think it's your challenge drew
i think it's the company's challenge
because they're already starting to
question issues anyway they probably
were when you were uh still there and
not on your way out the door i don't
think this is your cross to bear it
feels like it i think you're a good guy
but i don't think it's that big of an
issue i think you've got to take the
high road
now you can define what the high road
means to you the high road to me in this
situation means
i'm going to say something like you just
uh shared which is hey
you need to make your own observations
you need to ask your own questions
this is no longer the right place for me
i definitely have some issues but um
that is between you and you need to give
them another leader that they need to be
talking to um i think you take the high
road here and less is more yeah he's
feeling this moral obligation to kind of
save them it's not his job to save him
but i think he's got to go he can be he
can be very respectful he doesn't have
to trash the company on his way out
that's right but i think the team is
going to start to see the writing on the
wall as more and more leaders leave and
team members leave and they go i yeah we
see this yeah it's not his job to answer
their questions thanks for the question
drew appreciate that all right let's go
to the phone lines this hour they are
open if you want to give us a call
triple eight eight two five
five two two five gisele joins us in new
orleans
let's go giselle welcome to the show how
are you
hi george hi ken how you all doing today
great how can we help
well first of all i just want to give a
shout out to the youtube community
they've been super helpful already um
that's awesome to hear question is
yeah my question is um real quick so i'm
i'm on technically on baby step seven
uh i'm 12. what do you hold on what do
you mean technically that always worries
me but i'm currently
i guess my birthday's at the end of the
month but um
so 27 28 but i am renting at the moment
i think you missed the point of george's
question uh how are you technically in
baby step seven
oh because i'm i'm renting at the moment
and i do have my
baby step 3b done oh i would like to buy
a house later on in life ah good for you
okay very good okay so you've cut you're
kind of in that four to six land you've
started investing 15
yes okay and you've got the down payment
saved but you're not ready to buy
correct yeah i'm trying to wait till
later on in life to buy good food good
discipline all right so what's your
question today
yeah so i'm currently contributing to a
traditional 401k i have i have a bit
in there but i recently found out my
company also offers a roth 401k so i
guess my question is should i
uh since i'm still young convert my full
traditional to the roth 401k and then
just start contributing to the roth 401k
or leave the traditional and just switch
to contributing to the roth 401k the
latter is what you want to do i would
leave the traditional over here right
now we don't do that until we're at baby
step 7 with a paid for house that is
when we can take the tax hit and when
it's worth it because otherwise we want
that money going towards the house so
leave in the traditional side begin
investing in that roth side you've got
the right mentality this is going to be
a much better plan for you
at your age to be able to get that money
tax-free
on the roth side and pay taxes on it now
okay sounds great yeah thank you so much
i really appreciate it yeah way to go
she's disciplined she's on her way yeah
all right let's move on to seattle
washington justin joins us there justin
what is going on
hey guys how's it going great how can we
help
so my girlfriend's parents convinced my
girlfriend that credit score matters and
they got her a credit card now she plans
on using that credit card to buy a car
oh boy how do i convince her that
that is a very bad idea and that she
needs to have
a surgery with her credit card and get
rid of it
well a simple answer justin sell the
girlfriend
there it is
hey
george campbell ladies and gentlemen
i'll be here all week yeah
not a bad idea i'll add to that really
quickly because george will give you
some really tactical advice i think you
uh
i think you fake the snowflake syndrome
justin are you aware of what this is
i am not this is a passive aggressive
you ghost her for a little bit give her
the silent treatment and you make her
she she's like why why is justin not you
know what i mean like total silence this
is what women do very well to men the
silence
shoulder the cold shoulder and the guys
trying to figure out what's going on i
think you reverse it and you just really
and the snowflake syndrome part of it is
you act like you're very offended or
that you're shook
you're shook by her the suggestion that
she
would buy a car on a credit card and
just let it let her see how it just
really freaks you out man justin i know
we've been unhelpful so far so well i
think that'll help with this
conversation it might it'll set you up
for george's tech justin you you like
this girl right how long have you been
together
yeah we've been together for coming up
on five years now oh five
there a future here i'm wondering what
have the money conversations been like
clearly you've talked about your values
around money right
yeah so i definitely want to
like stay debt-free have no credit cards
my parents have been following you guys
for years and they're getting out of
debt uh using
your guys's method and i just want to
take the next step and i want to become
a millionaire but credit cards are not
the way to go well i think you have an
honest conversation that isn't attacking
her it's not hey you got to cut up the
card today it's hey listen my plan is to
become a millionaire i'd love for you to
be a part of that plan as we move
towards marriage and i know that a
credit card is not going to be helpful
in getting there and here's why and i
can give you a third-party tool we did
an episode all about this on my podcast
the fine print and it is episode seven
the dirty truth behind your credit score
we also have one in episode two the true
cost of credit card rewards so here's
what i'll do listen to that together yes
sit down listen to it and it'll spark
some conversation
because i think the reason she wants to
get the credit card can uh you we could
argue again say well listen we just
proved to you that that's not that's not
the case you don't need your credit
score to do any of this stuff and
there's easy ways around it you can live
your life without the score you can live
your life without the card and you can
live your life without debt
so justin i'm gonna encourage you to do
both of those things and get on the same
page and truthfully if you can't align
on those values i don't see this being a
long-term relationship beyond this it's
already a long term at five five years
man justin we gotta get this figured out
pretty quick man
what i don't wanna
i didn't wanna propose until we got this
straightened out absolutely
i know that the number one cause of
divorce is money problems this guy gets
it justin listen we're rooting for you
man i want her to get on the same page i
don't want it to become her parents
versus your opinion that's a dangerous
game to play so get her on board if not
we might have to to sell the girlfriend
i yeah really i really like the uh shock
and awe there we go be sensitive about
it that puts this hour of the ramsey
show in the books we'll be back with you
before you know it
[Music]
hey folks ken coleman here did you know
the ramsay show is one of the most
popular podcasts in the world it's your
daily dose of advice on life and money
check out all of our shows from the
ramsey network wherever you listen to
podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions this is the ramsay show where
america hangs out to have a conversation
about your life your money your work
your purpose your career
your toxic boss we are here for you i'm
george campbell joined today by ramsay
personality ken coleman the phone lines
are open triple eight eight two five
five two two five is the number to call
that's triple eight eight two five
five two two five
wayne kicks off this hour in kansas city
wayne welcome to the ramsey show
hi thanks for taking my call absolutely
how can we um
so i've got a 21-year old going on 22
year old son
who
uh been estranged with for about the
past seven or more years and he's
recently recently reconnected are
redeveloping our relationship
but he he has um
he's graduated from high school he tried
college for about a year and a half and
decided that it wasn't for him but in
the midst of all that he was battling a
mental health issue which has now been
addressed and he's on the path to
recovery
with
you know all the proper
you know medical support
but he has never had a job he doesn't
have any money
and he just is feels stuck and hopeless
about moving on
with his life and i want to be able to
help him
the best i can and i i've heard of your
books the proximity principle and the
paycheck to
purpose
purpose there we go yeah and i didn't
know if i didn't know if either one of
those would be good or if there's some
other resource that i could help him or
get him connected with yeah well i think
well here's the word yeah here's what
we're going to do today i'm going to
give you the from paycheck to purpose
book and i'm also going to give you the
get clear career assessment which is a
20 minute online assessment
that will really help him because he can
answer questions he doesn't have to
think he just answers questions and it's
going to help him it'll also give you a
conversation
to have with him once he gets his
results on talent passion and mission
and and begins to see the purpose
statement and whether it's 100 accurate
or not because he's not a whole
you know uh he doesn't have a whole
bunch of experience
it doesn't matter it's a great
conversation point but
um okay but i'm just curious uh because
you've been out of his life for a while
now you're back in would you
be able to confidently tell me what you
think his top
talents are
not super specific i don't want to put
you on on the spot as much as i i this
is where we want to start with him and
i'll unpack it in a second what would
you say that he has the most to offer
the world at work from a talent
standpoint
well
he has actually
specifically told me at one point that
he would like to be
a movie script editor
and that's very specific he loves movies
good um he's also very you know like
most of today's generation is very
heavily into online gaming um and you
know and he's also mentioned something
about wanting to work in a comic book
store or something along those lines
just to get started i'm not talking
about for life long no i understand okay
so so i want to go back to the question
and i want you to tell me
i want you to tell me what you think
he's really good at but but i want to
pause
because in those in the answers you gave
me that's actually
what we need to start with he just needs
a job
to get him out of this rut that he's in
so for instance if he could get a job at
a comic book store and he's only making
12 an hour or good heavens in today's
environment he's probably going to start
at 15 for all i know but that's good
because now he's working
and he is making money
and coaching along with how to you know
like by the way we'll give you we'll
give you any financial resources today
that'll help him
um and teach him about money and he gets
a little mojo
he's no longer
stuck
because he's actually working and he's
making money and he just happens to be
working maybe not the most exciting job
in the world but he's in an area that
he's interested in all right so that's
the first thing right okay but i want to
go back to
what do you think his top talents are if
you were to tell me people skills or
some type of technical hard skill what
would you say he's best at doing
i would say at this point from what i
know it's mostly technical on the
technical side okay great he's he knows
he is on top of the latest and greatest
technology i mean he's blowing me out of
the water
with the stuff he talked with the stuff
he talks to me about
you know he knows every everything about
all the latest phones and games and sure
um on online
uh is he verbal is he is he verbally
gifted has he always done well ver in
verbal type classes like maybe english
or
reading comprehension does he have
strong verbal skills
yes he does all right that's what i'm
looking for and that matches up to what
he told you
while it's super specific he's 21 and i
actually love when a 21 year old or
somebody young can give you something
very specific doesn't mean that's where
they're going to end up but it is a
really clear clue and so dad listen to
me
you just told me he's verbally gifted
and he told you he wants to be a movie
script editor that's super specific but
what he's saying is i want to work with
words
i'm intrigued by stories
and narratives and words because see a
person who's an editor whether it be
film editing audio editing
or copy editing
is a detailed person by nature is that
is that lining up with what you know
about your son
oh huge oh there we go he's very
detail-oriented he notices details and
not only does your son notice details
it makes them happy when they're in
order right when things are in order the
way they're supposed to be
absolutely okay so here's the deal we
want to steer him into those
conversations hey son okay i love the
idea about the movie script eddie what
are some other like editing
detail-oriented things around
storytelling and things of nature and
get him just have fun conversations
because you've been out of his life for
seven years this is good dad son stuff
but it's got a deeper purpose to it
don't try to help him figure it all out
just say that's really great there's a
clue here you're good at that stuff i
was talking to your mom and i was
talking to your old english teacher and
and begin to show him evidence that
there is a pattern
of talents in his life okay now the get
clear career assessment we're going to
give you it's also going to pull a lot
of this out but what i want you to do is
help him and encourage him just to get a
decent hourly job or maybe two part-time
jobs in areas of interest for him it
could be at the bottom rung of the
ladder dad it doesn't matter because we
need to get this kid some momentum right
now as he begins to discover
more about what he could do where he
could do it and how he gets there and
the book from paycheck to purpose is
going to explain the entire path and
we'll give you the assessment as well
the get clear career assessment i'm
pumped for him and another thing he
could do is even you know in kansas city
i'd go hey what high school film classes
college film classes maybe i could jump
in and volunteer and start to get my
feet wet i love that idea editing some
of these movie scripts at a low level to
get some experience i love that there's
a lot of things you can do practically
and i love him jumping in this and i
love a dad who just wants to encourage a
sound like that we need more dads like
that yeah you know this is this isn't
just for wayne it's just for other
parents when your kid or somebody in
your life just a friend or family tells
you they're stuck
push back gently on that they're not
stuck
they're scared i tell you this it's one
of two things they're scared of
something happening or they doubt that
something can happen
fear and doubt that's what makes them
feel stuck get to the source of that
how do we alleviate the doubt or
alleviate the fear and now we're unstuck
those are the enemies of impact hang on
the line wayne we're going to get you
those resources thanks for the call
wayne this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
look i love real estate and i want you
to have a house but i don't want a house
to have
you
that's why you need to get in touch with
churchill mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for
you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice
basically they care that's why we call
them ramsey trusted you can achieve
debt-free home ownership and churchill
is here to help go to their site
churchillmortgage.com ramsey to start
your approval or get more information
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm
george campbell joined today by ken
coleman listen guys we all know time is
important it's more precious than money
shiny toys or winning certificates at
work
and like spending money from an account
when you don't know how much is in it we
never know how much time we have
so if you could do one thing that would
make the time you have even more
worthwhile wouldn't you do it
sure you would we get that and we want
you to have everything you need to be
well
that's why we're partnering with
betterhelp to give you a month of free
one-on-one weekly therapy when you
pre-order a copy of dr john delony's
book own your past change your future
who does that that's incredible you're
never too old or too young to improve
your health and make your relationship
stronger and your free month of
one-on-one weekly therapy will help you
get the tools that you need to change
your future because you'll get matched
up with a therapist based on your
specific needs this is a life-changing
combo dr john's book own your past
change your future it'll make you laugh
maybe even cry and it will challenge you
for sure
when you take the steps that dr d
outlines and take advantage of the free
therapy you will also be transformed
this is an incredible deal get your free
therapy sessions by pre-ordering own
your past change your future for only 20
bucks at ramseysolutions.com
today
good stuff adam joins us up next in
minneapolis adam welcome to the ramsey
show
hey george and ken how you guys doing
great how can we help
um just curious i have a roth option in
my 401k at my job
which i'm currently putting eight
percent in that gives me the full match
that they'll provide
um within it though i can pick the funds
and things that i want to choose and i'm
just curious if i can use that vehicle
for my full 15
or if i should take the other seven and
you know use an elp and put into a roth
or whatever that's a great question adam
so you're saying you've got the roth
you're doing the eight percent match and
you're going hey what do i do with the
other seven
correct yeah well i'll tell you what i
personally do and that might make the
answer real simple for you i do all 15
of my investing in our company roth 401k
here ramsay solutions
because we have some great investment
options so that's what it comes down to
if it's all roth that's what we want
you're getting the match which roth
comes next you've already got the roth
and so it comes down to do we have good
options to invest in in these funds do
we have good uh performing funds with a
great track record that that would be
good for your future and so it sounds
like you have that
correct yeah then i keep it simple ken i
like to just go all 15 it's on autopilot
i never even see my paycheck and then
one day we just become millionaires and
let's point out here maybe for new
listeners
uh or new viewers that that's your 15
that's not including the match that's
right 15 of your check and then whatever
ramsey solutions matches is in addition
to that that's right so he's got eight
percent but he's already putting in
eight percent to get that match so we're
gonna do an additional seven right
fantastic adam way to go man
thank you guys absolutely
all right we're moving on to dayton ohio
sierra joins us there how are you
hi guys
uh thank you for taking my call
um so i'm at the crossroads right now in
my life especially financially
um i just don't know why it's my next
step hey sierra
sierra could you adjust your phone a
little bit you sound like you're in a
tunnel
i apologize is that better a little bit
let's try it let's just keep it close to
your mouth as possible go ahead
okay
so um
like i was saying i'm just at a
crossroads right now in my life
especially financially
i don't know my next step
and i'm just hoping for help from you
guys um or where or how
you know how do i go from here and
succeed
okay so what's going on tell us about
the situation
okay so the situation is
i was homeless um
april of uh prior to april of last year
i moved into a two-bedroom apartment um
small
um
and it was fairly surprising um
up until around november december
when funds were getting low i wasn't
able to work as much i've got some
medical issues going on and
um
my availability
when i could work was only part time and
i was working through attempt agency
i left the temp agency to go help a
friend who has a business um doing tax
preparation
and told them you know i needed you know
my situation you know what my bills were
and they led me to believe that they
could help well i got into that job and
um
it just wasn't covering any of my bills
um
my lease was up in april
and
i'm not employed right now
um i have zero money coming in
i have about
9 000 in savings
my debt is
200 on a credit card and the rest is
about 3 300 in student loans
i'm in school currently for business
online
i have two children in home they're ages
three and five
and um
you know at april i don't once my lease
is up i don't know what to do i don't
have anywhere to go
um i don't have anything lined up i have
no income coming in and i'm just
overwhelmed
i'm so sorry sierra so you said the the
kids
where are they
um my two children and in the home
they're three and five okay so they're
with you
yes okay
well are you cash flowing school right
now
are you going to death i'm sorry are you
cash flowing the the school
um i have uh loans and financial aid
okay so the loans the 3 300 you
mentioned
that's it right now and are able to cash
flow the rest of it or
are you gonna have to go further into
debt
um
i mean i'll accumulate more alone as as
i continue in school i'm not done until
the end of next year what are you trying
to
what kind of degree are you trying to
get or more importantly where do you
think that degree is going to take you
what's the aim
so it's a degree in business
to do what
well i haven't decided uh-huh
um this is more like the fundamental
um
skill based type you know it's just
associates right now okay so sierra
george is gonna give you some very
tactical financial advice but i want to
drop this in really quick hand it back
to george okay
you need to get a job this is the
hottest job market
in the history of our country
i'm not trying to make it
sound just effortless but i am telling
you
you need a job and that and i understand
you got two little ones at home but
you're going to have to figure that out
because you need some income coming in
the door
and i would pause this the school stuff
too because i
you got to get your financial house in
order the school will always be there if
we even need it
uh george take it over from here she is
she needs a job i want to make sure we
have we have aim for what this degree is
going to do before we just get one to
get one well that's not important right
now so sarah on the financial side
here's what i want you to do i know you
got 9 000 to your name but i want you to
pay off the credit card and the student
loan today that's about 3 500 total
okay so that's going to leave you with 4
500 to your name so you've got your
starter emergency fund i don't know what
three to six months of expenses looks
like for you but that would be the next
goal because what that's going to give
you is some financial peace it's going
to give you a stable foundation so when
you do have income coming in it's not
going back out to lenders and if you do
have a job loss you're going to be okay
for a few months while you find a new
one does that make sense
cool
does it scare you to lose some of that 9
000 right now
just right now it does
um
you know when i when i
had income coming in
not so much
yeah well you're going to get that real
soon because like ken said you're going
to go get a job this week and those
payments are going to get freed up and
so you're going to have actually more
cash flow coming in when you do have a
job because none of it is going to
lenders anymore sierra let me just
encourage you on something very
practical
walmart is offering just an hourly
position they're offering tuition
i mean you shouldn't have to pay for
that tuition if you want to go work at
walmart go work at walmart right now
there's no shame in that you got to go
get some income
hang on the line i want to give her from
paycheck to purpose read the book when
you have a little bit of spare time on
that big picture george what else we
want to give her on the financial stuff
i'm going to send you a copy of the
total money makeover as well to go along
with that to help you on the financial
side but sierra you can do this you've
gotten beaten down and we want to give
you some hope that it doesn't have to
stay this way and you don't have to stay
in the cycle you can get out of this
there is a lot of hope for you we're
cheering you on this is the ramsay show
[Music]
chaos
that's what it can feel like when your
business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by oracle the number one cloud financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by oracle including ramsey
solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite gives you the
visibility and control of the things you
need to grow like your financials
inventory hr planning budgeting and more
all in one dashboard go to netsuite.com
ramsey right now to get their free white
paper jump start your cfo career
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm
ramsay personality george campbell
joined today by ken coleman
you know ken i am a millennial and
therefore i'm on like every social media
platform there is out there not only are
you not on it george but there are times
like earlier today
uh i needed to ask you a question i
wanted to do something fun on the old uh
instagram it was tech support was it
sure how to do it who do i go to george
cam it made me feel young and it made
you look old so i'm a big fan of yeah
yeah well i i embrace it so one of these
platforms everyone's heard about it is
tick-tock it's very polarizing people
have a lot of feelings about it but i'll
tell you there's some is that right yeah
there's some there's some great
entertaining content some great content
creators the same people who make i've
done some things on the tick tock yeah
they're great by the way i like to call
it the tick tock that makes you you're
even older well that's the whole point
it's kind of a built-in joke drives my
kids nuts i can imagine it's driving me
nuts you know what else i say the google
oh boy drives my kids nuts hey they
asked me a question and i literally go i
don't know look it up on the google
you're one step closer to john delaney
calling it the internets
we got it guys it's funny
john and i are in our 40s leave us alone
as long as you guys are all right so
anyway the tick tock so here's the deal
i i get a lot of financial type videos
because of the things i engage with and
see yeah you're an expert and you're
relevant yes and a lot of this advice
i'm going to say 99
is just abhorrent financially i can't
even immediately make blood boil and
it's encouraging a lot of young people
to do a lot of stupid things oh sure and
i can see the future where they're
hopefully calling into our show asking
for help because they did a dumb thing
so i want to play a video and get your
reaction uh and see what you're thinking
so we're gonna play a tick tock we're
gonna go picture-in-picture here
you ready
very excited roll that beautiful bean
footage here we go
this is the number one real estate
investing strategy that i use to become
a millionaire oh that's a little over
the top
buy a property for a good price or below
market value that preferably needs some
tlc okay our renovation repair the
property a lot of jump cuts make it
attractive take the furl tenants
rent out the property to a tenant with
good credit oh boy
our
refund oh geez oh boy once you have
revenue coming into your property and
you build some equity you go back to the
bank that's it get it nothing should be
free
repeat this process again with the money
the bank gave you and buy another
revenue property of course
oh here we go
and instagram okay
so first of all there was already a
little too much pep in that interview
and that whole thing
but then she went dick doc at the end
and i completely forgot everything she
said before that well she's got a future
as an actress if the if the real estate
thing doesn't work out a lot of acting
going on there the real estate thing is
not gonna work out for her george well
this is a try this is an old playbook
this is old school brought to a new
school platform and here's what it's
doing the young kids out there kids in
their 20s and their 30s my age they're
going this is my path because i am
saddled with student loan debt i'm
living off credit cards i've got a car
payment i need a way to make a lot of
money fast go into debt now even more
debt and then sell it oh no rent it to a
renter and repeat the price she
basically said go into debt have
somebody rent it
and then repeat the process go into more
debt
renters of a young dave ramsey
pre-bankruptcy see this was my point
this is what dave did before the tick
tock oh boy can you imagine dave doing
that video 35 40 with hair
sorry
you just visualized it didn't you with a
fake leather jacket and a big chain
maybe dave doing that like all those
years ago
behind him yeah here's the deal what's
the danger in that george now we're
having fun yeah she's a little peppy
well uh but that's the thing these kids
do this by the way real quick thing she
was i don't know how old she was but
it's at some point there's types of tic
tocs you shouldn't do like there's types
of clothes i shouldn't wear as a 47 year
old man yeah it's the same thing well i
digress we'll talk about the advice here
so our plan as you know if you've
listened to the show for 10 seconds is
to become debt free and stay debt free
because we have found based on lots of
in-depth research with our millionaire
study based on 10 million people
following our plan
that the best path to financial success
to building wealth
is to become debt free and stay debt
free including your mortgage so what
this advice is saying which is
diametrically opposed in case you're
wondering um is saying that you need to
maximize every possible dollar of bank
debt you can get access to
so here's the idea leverage debt out
your eyeballs to have maximum cash flow
and hope that everything works out
perfectly on paper yeah and then you
will
in a matter of years have a private jet
that you can pose next to because of the
instagram influencers you follow and
they're driving this drivel into
people's heads okay let's talk about
real practically what could go wrong
with what she could go wrong well no
seriously hold on i'm gonna tee you up
you're the financial expert right sure
so you buy the first house like like uh
like uh uh pepe told us to
okay
and right now it's the top of the market
certainly the united states yeah we've
had you're gonna put as little down as
possible if you're following this little
down as possible everybody stay with me
let me tell you the facts we've had a
moratorium on
evictions
rentals right we've had a moratorium on
bankruptcies or foreclosures
trump and biden continuing this
that's gonna lift here pretty soon yeah
and we're gonna see a lot of bad stuff
hitting the streets and it's gonna
create more supply which what happens
george when we have more supply and less
demand bad things housing prices go down
now you bought a house at the top i'm
just talking now worth a lot less it's
worth a lot less and you still have that
giant mortgage and yet you still have
the mortgage and you still got to pay
for it and you're hoping you're hoping
that you can get a good solid tenant
who's going to pay on time every time
but you may have to drop the rent
because the rent you can't charge what
the rent was at the top of the market
which hurts your profits because you're
stuck paying this giant mortgage payment
because you had nothing down on this
property yeah then what continues to
happen there's property taxes there's
insurance there's all the maintenance
what happens if you can't pay that
george well foreclosure could happen oh
yeah yeah yeah so now you go back to
instagram and you like this out what do
you do what has she got for you on insta
on tick tock after that happens to you
well then is there another video they
don't talk about when it goes wrong it's
all the promises of what could be and
all the money you could make in the cash
flow that could happen
could could could could could
then we've made our point we find real
estate advice from the tick tock i think
we're going to see a whole new
generation of the young dave ramsey's
who are filing for bankruptcy and going
well that was a bad move i was leveraged
with 10 properties and then you know a
million dollars in debt and i've seen
these tick tocks people bragging that
they're 15 million dollars in debt oh
yeah
by the way can i point out something
else on all these platforms whether it
be facebook instatic talk anytime you
see one of these here's how you get
really stinking rich videos they always
play the part the giant fur standing
next to a private jet real estate guru
they're enticing people into a trap and
it is all about stuff
every one of those videos by the way i'm
going to step on some toes here i don't
care because every one of those
influences that do this they are selling
an unbelievably extravagant lifestyle
yep they're not selling purpose they're
not selling financial peace they're not
selling
significant contribution to your fellow
man they're not it's a wolf in sheep's
clothing it's they're selling you is
risk it's all lifestyles of the rich and
famous caviar
all that crap it's a trap
it's a trap
every time it's a trap they're leveraged
out of their eyeballs and they manage to
somehow dodge the bullet and they're
trying to recreate it and they're
getting rich not off of their real
estate strategies they're getting
courses off of their courses that tell
you how to do it like they oh there i've
gone into oh man i stepped in yeah riled
up stepped in it there a little bit i'm
not mentioning names here's the problem
you see a video like that and you're a
20-something-year-old who's strapped
with debt who doesn't have a great
income it knocks like a fastlane baby
and they go absolutely you're gonna do
this
they get starry-eyed they only see the
upside and they're delusional about the
downside by the way there's no hard work
in that it's just go down and get a loan
and then play out this seven step
process that johnny rich boy told me on
instagram and do a bunch of cash out
refi to stay in debt for the rest of
your life
it's just a it's a it's a giant
motivational trap
don't do this guys please please please
if you see financial advice on take doc
that sounds too good to be true it is
it's a trap and if you follow the trends
you will fall for the traps that's what
i say ken
george you said it well thank you say it
again if you follow the trends you will
fall for the traps
and that that goes with crypto and nfts
and zero down real estate you name it
there's always a new trend out there
that's the newest get rich quick scheme
and i'll tell you read through proverbs
i don't care if you're a person of faith
or not read through proverbs it speaks
against all these get-rich-quick schemes
that we're seeing today ken by the way
have you noticed all the get rich advice
on social and all the vhs tapes years
years gone by i'll tell you what that is
on a commercial break whatever thank you
you know it's never free what you always
got to pay for the course oh there it is
i tell you how to get rich but you got
to pay for the course 29.99 do it the
slow way that's the best way to get rich
and stay rich yeah this is the ramsay
show
[Music]
[Music]
this is the ramsay show i'm george
campbell joined today by ken coleman our
scripture of the day comes from
ecclesiastes 5 verses 4 and 5. when you
make a vow to god do not delay to
fulfill it he has no pleasure in fools
fulfill your vow it is better not to
make a vow than to make one and not
fulfill it that's integrity that's good
stuff phillips brooks said character may
be manifested in the great moments but
it is made in the small ones
that's good both all about integrity
there
all right let's head to the phone lines
josh joins us next in west palm beach
josh how you doing
hey i'm doing great guys how are you
wonderful how can ken and i help
yeah well i've got a bit of a pickle
here so
my wife sweet fiona and i bought our
first house down here in jupiter florida
two years ago right before florida
exploded real estate wise
so we got a good deal on the house we've
got some debt uh we both have student
loans we've got a couple cars things
like that and now we're trying to get
serious about uh following the baby
steps
so we're on baby step two
uh i've got an opportunity i mean i
guess everybody here does i got an
opportunity to sell our home
and make a a pile of money on it up to
200 000
take away profit which would get us out
of debt um but of course it would put us
in a situation where we'd have to rent
the rent's really high here
may end up having to move to another
state i don't know i'm i'm ready to make
a radical move but i just want to get
some advice and make a sound to it sure
well i'll tell you up front uh just
blank statement saying hey sell the
house i'm not going to say that it's a i
know that we're at the top of the market
right now and it feels like a good idea
but it could put you in a lurch so let's
get some numbers here and walk through
this process what's your household
income
about 90 000.
okay and how much debt
between the two of us just under two
hundred thousand wow
and what how much are those on the car
loans each
uh
thirty thousand and seven thousand
all right
and what's the car worth that thirty
thousand dollar loan what's that car
actually worth right now
uh right about right about thirty
thousand okay
and what about the seven thousand dollar
car i'm guessing
it's probably worth about uh nine or ten
okay
so here's my thinking before we go
selling the house what if we went and
sold these cars and and got something
that can get us around for now
to get this debt number lower
okay
and then with this income can you guys
work overtime can you work extra jobs
can you sell stuff
yeah i've actually just picked up a
second job that's commission based i
just i really don't know what it's going
to bring in so i've already uh you know
kind of gotten started with that the
other thing is and i know you guys hate
this but um about 110 000 of the student
loans i'm a high school assistant
principal and i'm on track to have a
public student loan forgiveness i think
i'm about two and a half years away from
that assuming you know it still exists
and everything but uh so i don't know
how much hope i should put in that none
um as well
i have very little hope i mean if you're
two years out and you want to ride it
out to because this is a large number
right what how much would be forgiven
110 000 yeah i mean that's a big chunk
um but i i just don't know that i'd go
selling the house now there you do have
200 grand versus a 90 grand income like
this is going to be a journey for you
guys because you can't put more than
what 30 grand a year right now based on
your income towards the debt right yeah
so the 200 does not include your your
mortgage debt correct
no it does not yeah so most of it is
your student loan because we got 110 on
that then you got 30 on the car so we're
already 140 so
man i tell you george is right
i got to tell you i'd sell that car
because right now used cars are at the
top of their market too this is not
going to last
so i i would cash out that car now
that's 30 grand dude one swoop and that
gives you some momentum yeah i mean
based on the numbers i'm seeing if you
wanted to sell the house because that
would be a clean you'd be out of debt
completely right if you sold the house
today got 200 grand but there's a lot of
headaches that come with that closing
costs like you said you're gonna have to
go rent somewhere i'm guessing that's
way more than your mortgage right now
right
yeah it's a bit more yes
and so that part worries me i'd be
crunching some numbers because here's my
parameters here's what's going on my
head if i can get rid of this debt in
two years i'm not selling the house even
three years if i can get rid of all this
debt in three years by hustling getting
my income up selling the car selling
everything i can
that makes me feel a lot better about it
but if you're saying hey it's gonna be a
five-year journey to get rid of this
debt then i may go yeah we're selling
the house and it stinks and it's gonna
hurt we're going to pay way more in rent
but we're going to set ourselves up for
a better future
when you mentioned the out of state
option
it's when you were laying out well if we
sell the house we may have to move out
of state is that something that you were
already kicking around and open to or is
that one of those if we sell the house
this becomes one of the options was it
first or later
well you definitely read me there so
we just look around at what happened in
florida we love it in florida we're
transplants we moved here from virginia
uh because we love it here but um it's
just going absolutely insane here with
the house prices and the rent prices and
stuff and we just kind of think like if
we sold the house you know we get the
big financial win but then if we have to
go turn around and pay you know 3 500 a
month in rent then it kind of just
defeats the purpose of it so it would be
almost like because i work in public
education and i have inner city
experience i can basically go get the
same job i have here anywhere else right
kind of just i thought well why don't i
just go move somewhere that makes you
know or my money goes further or i can
actually afford to live it's nice
i don't want to offer yeah i don't want
to uproot my family necessarily we did
just have our first child 15 months ago
don't do it
dude that's awesome congratulations
don't do it don't do it here's why
um
even in virginia you'd have to go to
some really rural areas of virginia to
for it to make sense anyway any kind of
metropolitan area in virginia
um it's not like the housing prices are
that much different and to strap
yourself because of rent look you guys
can do this i'd rather see you hustle uh
maybe upgrade your gig
you know um
and you both just get after it i i
wouldn't sell the house now yeah i'm
gonna be on a strict monthly budget i'm
gonna decrease every expense do an audit
and try to squeeze as much as you can
out of that income and on top of that i
want you to get a bigger shovel so that
this isn't a five-year journey that's
just too much of a slog but we're
rooting for you man good luck whatever
route you choose all right let's take
one more adam joins us in new york city
adam welcome to the show
hi george hi ken how you doing we're
having a blast what's up
um i have two questions uh one which is
probably very common
for your show and the second one i'm not
quite sure how to deal with so um i
wanna literally just dump my job the job
i'm working for
i know the people for like 15 years they
are all my like like
pretty much like friends
and i don't know how to deal with the
guilt but i am completely burned out i
don't see my future in the company i'm
working for okay all right all right so
let me let me address the first one
because we have uh just about two
minutes so we got to move quickly uh
are you doing anything wrong are you
doing anything illegal so are you doing
anything unethical no absolutely no
absolutely no i know it was a setup
yeah
adam listen it was a setup question
you're not doing anything illegal nor
are you doing anything unethical so stop
feeling guilt
they're going to survive without you and
if they can't survive without you they
wouldn't survive with you do you
understand what i'm saying
yes so stop it you're a good dude you're
burned out you know it's time to move on
move on and don't look back what's the
next question
so the the
the next question is basically um
uh i have i have some options so so so i
have some options with a little work i
have something just coming up and uh
because as i said like i know those
folks for 15 years were working for 15
years together they are my friends i
just
really don't know how to quit that's the
thing you don't know how to quit how to
have that conversation oh so so the
first question was guilt and i answered
that when the second question is how to
actually do it
oh this is cool i know that basically
just you know talk to them and put the
paper away oh i get it you want to do it
tastefully i get the question here's the
answer
quit how you would want someone to quit
you
okay how would you want somebody to quit
you adam
uh
so but
i wouldn't basically because if i run my
own business i would just uh try to keep
the people and i know but okay what
would you do with kindness and respect
yeah leave well
leave well whatever leave well means to
you do that
be classy
don't burn the bridge
just leave the way you would want
someone to leave you is the point and
then you don't have to worry about it
you're going to upset them a little bit
they're going to be disappointed sure
but that's not up to you
what you're responsible for is how you
treat them be thankful for the
opportunity
be gracious in your opportunity how you
offer to help transition
and be classy as a fellow people pleaser
i relate i get it 100 you don't need to
overthink it yeah
good luck adam thanks for calling puts
this hour of the ramsey show in the
books my thanks to my co-host ken
coleman all the folks in the booth kelly
ben james zach nathan the whole gang and
they're keeping the show running and you
america we'll be back with you before
you know it until then remember to spend
wisely save intentionally and give
generously this is the ramsay show
[Music]
hey folks ken coleman here did you know
the ramsay show is one of the most
popular podcasts in the world it's your
daily dose of advice on life and money
check out all of our shows from the
ramsay network wherever you listen to
podcasts
[Music]
you